[Music]
hey guys spend a minute or two with me
as I talked to you about Ramadan a
blessed month of fasting you might ask
why do more than 1 billion Muslims
around the world abstain from food and
drink from dawn asunción for an entire
month each year I can tell you one thing
for sure it's not a hunger strike or an
unusual fad diet or madad nine months of
islamic calendar and in the last period
fasting during daylight hours that
purifies the soul and unites muslims and
the worship of the creator
among the many benefits of Ramadan is
that Muslims practice self-control and
experience what the world's hungry
experience on a daily basis Ramadan
provides numerous opportunities for
self-improvement making one more humble
generous and inclined towards good deed
many Muslims spend a month Ramadan
performing acts of charity and working
to quit bad habits like smoking or
backbiting and many of the other things
God Almighty in law has prohibited out
of his wisdom when the month is over
Muslims gather for either to do a
special back-breaking celebration that
involved thanking God for His mercy and
blessing greeting friends and relatives
and providing for the community support
fasting Muslims perform a vital act of
worship that was practiced by all Assam
prophets including Noah Abraham Moses
Jesus and Mohammed being the final and
last peace be upon them all God Almighty
Allah says in the Quran all you who
believe fasting is prescribed to you as
it was prescribed to those before you
that you may learn self-restraint and
become more God
is mindful of your Creator thank you my
friend
remember caring and sharing so like and
share this video and support painting
show we can't continue educating and
sharing the message of peace he's
acquired by submission to the little guy
with the world still on little blush
from adapt
[Music]